with the number of cases stabilizing the
state says it does not expect to see any
significant declines in the near future
hospitalizations are also stabilizing at
273 that is the lowest total number
since the nevada hospital association
began keeping track the state's decision
makers when it comes to the covet 19
mitigation task force met virtually
thursday morning
and we learned the mask mandate will
remain in place when the state turns
over control
to local governments on may first chair
caleb cage also
said that organizations such as the
gaming control board
will remain responsible for working with
and enforcing requirements at casinos
however there is one question that's
still outstanding
will restaurants have to meet social
distancing and coronavirus hygiene
requirements
cage said that is still being reviewed
the goal is to have a clear answer
early next week i don't want to get down
too into the weeds
of of where we are on that because
there's there are decisions yet to be
made
um but uh our goal
is to make sure we meet the uh the
spirit and the letter of the directive
going to
uh may 1st and local transition myleene
as far as schools and graduations go
schools may now apply for large
gatherings those events will transition
to
county starting may 1st vaccine
eligibility also expands next week to
include everyone
16 and up so far 25 percent of nevada
residents
have received at least one dose and the
state says it's expecting a significant
allocation next week along with an
expansion
of vaccination sites live in our
newsroom hector mejia
8 news now